Well, that
was fun.
Amy, you all right?
I don't know.
What's up?
I think I just thought
that I would be more
like the focal point?
Huh.
Were you not
the focal point?
No, no,
definitely not.
Like, I just-- it never
even occurred to me
that you would be
penetrating Phil.
Did I do that?
Are you sure?
Yes, yes.
I thought you felt
comfortable with Phil.
I do.
I usually do.
Phil...
Look, you've been
our pharmacist,
how long, three
years, okay?
We move closer
to another CVS.
I said, "Let's
stick with Phil,"
didn't I, okay?
She did.
Maybe I'm being over
sensitive but God,
I don't think so,
I don't think so.
What's the
problem, Amy?
I had an orgasm,
probably the biggest one
I've ever had in my life.
You Phil?
I didn't.
I didn't even
come close.
Nobody touched me.
I went to the bathroom
at one point.
You guys didn't
even realize...
No, it's too
late, Phil.
I just wish you
hadn't been yelling,
"This feels
so right."
Okay, how do you know I
wasn't talking about you?
This feels so right
with you , Phil!
Phil, Phil, Phil!
I'm penetrating Phil!